[Music]
in interesting strategy news Oh Daesan
they're submitted by average Joe okay la
is trying to fix its prostitution
problem by banning right turns at night
there's a prostitution where that of
course that's not la fix for it
Jesus I've never been approached by a
prostitute ever you look very prostitute
max have it on sunset then did Jesus
come to me and Northwestern because I
would like for something hey you looking
for a good time I never get that [ __ ]
there's prostitute looking people on
sunset
uh-huh oh yeah how'd you loose women out
there dude tons of loose man I thought
it was just people coming out of clubs
well there's a lot of that too but then
there's the ones that you're like okay I
know all girls those booking girls are
they considered yeah I forgot about that
they're all over that rap it is [ __ ]
Pookie when I first moved to LA I was
driving on Sunset and there was a lady
who was wearing like fishnets and
dollars [ __ ] and she was waving at me
and I just way back like thinking she's
just nice lady and then she full-on
turned around pretended to drop
something and then did a full bend over
and looked at me and I was like oh [ __ ]
she's like a prostitute oh [ __ ] then
what you do and then what her ball hired
happen now you became a done go cheap
motel and then what you do I licked your
feet and then I came on the floor if
class seats are great I'm gonna tell
enough Daniel there now he didn't came
on the floor I looked at her feet what
do you wouldn't that I'd like to read an
improper term not to be offensive that
they think they're going transsexual
transsexuals is that the transgender
gender may depend I guess
sexual after they have the surgery right
why do why do you need to know this
right there's a lot of those ones
especially at doctors aren't sunset
especially can make this drown right now
oh well I don't know but because we go
there no that was the gentlelady who
bent over I believe yes I believe yeah
they're saying now that there are these
new signs that say
there's no right turn between midnight
to 7:00 a.m. nightly they look like this
I mean rare no that's supposed to be for
the prostitution problem yes whatever
your hoover needs to pick you up how the
[ __ ] you supposed pick you up not their
specific stops right don't have that
yeah so it's on the corner of marathon
Street and Western Avenue so that's
where they yeah so now they're just
gonna move it's like a hilarious [ __ ]
what la comes up with as a solution is
so funny they did well it's not a
hundred percent proven that's because of
the signs but they did test this out
before and it did improve well I mean
honestly I feel like a lot of side
hustles are happier on it online now you
know like that's like having real estate
like that's like having a
brick-and-mortar and you all know that
he's doing that well right now so like I
feel like they're all on you know back
pages a little hotline call those
something-something craigslist or
Instagram yeah Instagram loose women
they're good I started noticing I I saw
somebody that I was like cool what do
you do you know I was just scrolling
through her stuff and I noticed that her
bio said DM is open and then she had
photos with other girls and Mike there
was a girl that I saw she was really
pretty so like obviously I'm a girl and
I'm a Beckham good this click good her
bio bio says DMS open LA New York Austin
Seattle yo did you see that [ __ ] on
Twitter I think make sense and they were
very like they had they had like the
pictures in every like hotel together
like night owls but like traveling all
over the place like you know like I
don't know he's smarter than me I would
just be like oh she likes to get the MC
nice travel just funny [ __ ] on Twitter
right now man yeah hilarious - so this
girl she's like a snapchat chick right
well you know when you like you pay
money to her snapchat and they show show
you like [ __ ] pics or stuff like
premiere prime oh really
yeah so that's like like amateur porn
[ __ ] right and so this dude she put up a
tweet put a picture of herself
and then she was like I'm open for
snapchat just DME whatever this dude
tweezer he was bought it your [ __ ]
head game sucks
I didn't see no [ __ ] it's [ __ ] blamed
all right and it got like so many
retweets she goes I don't even remember
who you were I remember everybody blah
blah blah and he goes that's funny and
he should receipt of him buying it
shameless you don't give a [ __ ] he goes
your head games terrible you didn't like
a no picture profile camp no his picture
was mean why would he do that though you
already bought per head game okay that's
the thing like you don't get Yelp
reviews for that how do you know that
the product that you know you're getting
me but don't do it don't put him on
blast like that maybe it just wasn't up
to his taste well he paid for it so he's
bitching about it
that's an American right and also if I'm
gonna bring in a lady you know I want
like I went you know it's got to be on
point better be on point you know you
know we won't try to find them on
Instagram you might want to find them on
a better side or something cuz portals
free and if you pay for it it better be
good if you pay for porno though bro
like you're kind of weird if you
download porno you're going to I want to
support the artists stop I'm not against
paying for porn I've thought about it
because the quality is just so much
better the quality is better but it
looks like it would be you know it if
you like stuff it's a little more niche
you can subscribe to a website that only
produces that type of thing I just am
well informed so I've known corn stones
over the years right and they told me
that they one of the major side hustles
that they get a lot of bread for it is
they'll do fetish videos for like
whatever specific thinks it'll make like
a video a personalized video for whoever
and that's all cool yeah yeah well they
like [ __ ] himself with a cucumber and
like then they make a salad and eat it I
had never told us before when I first
started streaming on Twitch I had a
person like this was like years ago I
had a guy like email me and he was like
hey I'll pay you money too if you send
me a video of you throwing up and I'm
like do it
I would have to like obviously I gotta
like buck with this guy and so I'm
asking I'm like well I just need some
more details and he was like I get to
choose the color you wear the food thank
you the color of the vomit he's he gets
he said you got to choose the color that
I wear and the food that I would eat for
it and like I just stop at lunch I
didn't ask for ray to know more but like
when I got when I got that I knew this
[ __ ] was serious I thought
somebody was just trolling me at first
so I was like haha gonna get these
screen caps but then he freaked me out
and I was like I'm not posting this
anyway [ __ ] find you five grand five
grand forgot for us for five grand now
dude some you girls are so [ __ ] weird
what if I let you pick what you wear how
about that if somebody BM me right now
it isn't paid David I want you to throw
up Porter listen but you got to do this
and say this [ __ ] other that's it what
else personally what's a month yeah we
get it clear because some brand deals
they'd like to come back with notes
later clear right now I'm going up for
you and I'm wearing heels yes my issue
with it personally would be that I'm
like very protective of like you know
myself especially like in a sexual
fashion and the fact that this person
that I don't know and I have no
connection to is using me for their
sexual pleasure like it's like that's
not oh how would love that one day I'm
not I would love for somebody says which
one well the ones are you Nate is that a
serious question the name was absolutely
not agreeable yeah he was a lot of
people saying please take those down
like that's not those naked photos I
lost like like 2,000 [ __ ] followers
but did I gain like $7 you put up naked
photos kind of sort of like I may be fun
if Instagram mr. gross he pulled his
underwear so [ __ ] far up you could
see everything oh my god
yeah you lucky girl yeah you missed it
it was amazing it's still very if you go
see it okay keep that down that's what
I'm saying yeah
but then girls can't post if they can
put it off the day I can't go paws
titties they can not they just have to
use a little thing to like blur out the
nipples like why but guys can do
shirtless [ __ ] I hate it yeah it's not
fair all right so yeah back to these
signs here to deter prostitution so
they're saying that this just gives more
of an excuse or like a reason for a cop
to pull over a car that has picked
someone up and then as soon as they turn
into like a residential area mommy see
they're gonna go do some [ __ ] so then
that's so if they're turning they're
making a right turn that means that they
they are doing an illegal turn because
it's not allowed during that time of the
day or night and so that's when they
will pull them over and then see like
who's in the car what's happening and
they can arrest people for prostitution
because obviously that's illegal so
they're setting up laws for people to
break so that they can pull them over
they can get an extra ticket money I
ain't even mad about that because
whoever whoever's out there still
driving around instead of like checking
look like the Internet you know I don't
know what you're doing this sounds real
sketchy pick a man why is prostitution
illegal I help some people yeah actually
I read this reddit story the other day
this was real interesting to me it was
about a guy that he was very Christian
and he saved his virginity for
prostitute work his girl he didn't his
girl really Christian and he saved his
virginity for her they get married after
like a couple years of dating and she
ends up sleeping with him and confesses
that she had lost her virginity in high
school and he wasn't good in bed and he
had been saving himself for her this
whole time so he started hiring
prostitutes so that he could learn how
to have sex and try to get her back in
this prostitute like on reddit posted it
and said like this is a really sad story
I was like damn I wonder how often that
happens like you know she shacked up
with my man it's like you weren't good
enough cuz like mommy and I have no
practice yeah what
the Virgin's expect ya like what do
y'all want but it's always there if
you're a virgin and she's a virgin and
she's like yes it's kind of sucks I
don't get the height you know I mean cuz
you both suck well not even that what
[ __ ] sucks is like he held up his end
of the bargain probably wasn't the best
I've heard your face yeah yeah yeah but
I thought that was so sad he was like
just going through ladies like trying to
like learning look and he's asking her
for like criticisms and stuff so that
like he could get better titties on
instagrams illegal prostitution is
illegal sounds like a bunch of [ __ ] that
dished oppresses women to me bro yeah
the whole economic rail for women as an
option does not exist why because of
male law and then they gon replace us
with robots just like the idea of Japan
yes they will mm-hmm yes they will
mm-hmm they're all want to be making
none money no the man makes the money
the man makes it a net you robot
prostitution is gonna be legal to
anything how we would it be there to be
in a world where prostitution is illegal
and it's like you hanging out with
people and it's like so how much not
weird oh yeah [ __ ] bizarre maybe it's
good it's gonna leak I mean Amsterdam's
that way and it's not like that that's
true and it's regulated and if you walk
through there the chicks are hotter than
[ __ ] yeah but they also have very kind
lighting
[Music]
[Music]